For the first doctor, we have three data points.
Data point one, well, it's observed value was 2.00 and the mean was 2.00.
It’s actually a distance of 0 from the mean.
The absolute deviation of this number, this observation, is 0.
What about this guy, 1.2 meters? Well, 1.2 - 2 is equal to 0.8, -0.8.
But since I don't really care whether they're overestimating or underestimating,
I’m going to always make these numbers positive which I do by taking the absolute value.
So, just call that + 0.8. This third measurement of 2.8, I get again a deviation of 0.8.
Now, for my three measurements, I have deviation of 0, 0.8, and 0.8.
That’s the deviation part. What about the average?
Well, you know how to do an average, you take the sum, 0 + 0.8 + 0.8 gives me 1.6
and we divide by a number of data points, so 1.6/3 is equal to about 0.53.
So, the average deviation for this first doctor was 0.53 and that unit there is meters.
We interpret this by saying when this doctor makes a measurement,
I can only say with confidence that she's probably within 0.53 meters
but even then that's not always true.
In fact, into these measurements, she was outside of that range.
The way we would write this is by saying the green-haired doctor measured
my height to be 2.00 meters plus or minus 0.53 meters.
Now, normal height within half a meter is not so helpful,
so let’s see what the purple-haired doctor said.
Can you tell me how the purple-haired doctor would state my height
including the average and the average deviation? Enter your answer here.